testy okay yeah so more about me my name
is Kara this is Steven my husband and we
own speed interactive which we've been
doing for about the last three years a
little over three years now and
basically we went it like we jumped in
feet first I think Steven hat Steven has
been doing code stuff for about ten
years prior to this at Oklahoma
Christian as their web development
director and then moved short time to an
agency that doing web stuff and it was
just not really his cup of tea and then
um I had been doing some freelance on
the side for a while since I was out of
school and so I I am a graphic designer
and that's kind of my background a lot
of branding work and InDesign and we
basically jumped in full like he quit
his job and I had already quit a while
back to stay home with babies and so we
were both doing this at the same time
and we started out kind of freelance and
then we decided okay we want to start
making the recurring monthly income so
we're going to add people and add
services and kind of start building up
an agency and so for like the last all
of 2017 we are we were saying like we're
an agency we do content development and
that kind of thing and sell our services
that way and just this last year we kind
of realized okay we've we've made a lot
of mistakes we don't necessarily know
how to sell our services and adding
people is just kind of adding to the
chaos and so we've actually cut back and
we're now kind of moving back to the
freelance side of things
in a more smart way maybe we've learned
from a lot of our mistakes we're
learning how to sell our services we're
learning what like actually appeals to
our clients and what's helpful for our
clients
and instead of just kind of not knowing
what we're doing we're working on
building up our business with the two of
us and making sure that we know how to
grow our business without you know
without just adding people adding
services adding time sold so um that's
what's been going on these last three
years and I'm hoping to kind of share
some of our mistakes with you today so
that you can learn from them instead of
doing them yourself
and so that's kind in the last three
years and I'll tell you there's um
there's four things before you jump into
freelance and I I was asking a little
while ago you you do freelance in the
back and then who else has done
freelance kimberley and you've done
freelance but everyone else is that is
freelance a goal for you is that
something that you are interested in
doing once you learn what you're doing
okay yeah so yeah before you jump into
that there's there's four things that
you need to understand and I will say
there are a ton of resources online like
google is your best friend when you're
getting started in this like so if
you're looking to you know pricing or
accounting or you know all that all the
technical stuff that gets you know the
background of what your are needing to
do Google is your best friend you can
find a lot of help online a lot of free
information but there's four things that
you need to understand and kind of work
towards for freelance if you want to be
successful and and I will say like a lot
of a lot of this like we kind of just
realized like okay we don't have a good
understanding of these things how
get that and we were paid we paid
consultants to figure this out so that's
always an option for you but um some
mistakes that we were making over these
last three years one we were very
attached
we were very up close and personal with
our deliverables in the actual product
that we sold we took a lot of pride in
our work which is a really good thing to
have it's good to be confident in what
you're doing but when I say we are too
attached to what we were selling what
what we're doing is we kind of put value
on our services that someone else
doesn't see like it's when you're kind
of up there working you're putting in
the hours you don't realize like what
someone else is seeing what your clients
actually value it's hard to communicate
to them the value of you know your time
or your expertise if all you're doing is
kind of if it's one-sided perspective of
your work um we didn't understand money
when we started what when we started it
out we were basically just trying to
make up our salary and for freelance
there's so much more that goes into
pricing your services than just making
up your salary um a lot of it is like of
course you want to survive and you want
to be able to pay your bills but there's
a lot more that goes into your cost than
just the time that goes into each
product or each deliverable and so and
I'll go into that too and then we didn't
understand value and that's kind of the
same as we are too attached to the
deliverables but we didn't really
understand how to communicate to our
clients in a way that they understand in
a way that kind of leads them to see
what why why they need us so yeah that's
that's like the big things
and I think that a lot of freelancers
don't think about you know how they're
going to actually sell their services or
how they're going to you know make up
their time and make make sure that they
are full have a full roster of clients a
lot of people just kind of jump in
blindly saying hey I got this cool thing
and that's actually one of the things I
love freelance for is that anyone can do
it anyone can jump in anyone has the
it's very accessible to people it's kind
of a great neutralizer because you don't
have to be part of a bigger company you
don't have to be dependent on you know
them just kind of feeding you like the
scraps you actually get to set your
prices and you know make the money that
you want to make through freelance and
if only like it was that easy and it
actually is easy you just have to kind
of know what those things are in order
to make that money um so yeah back to
the four things that you need to
understand if you can detach from your
product detach from the deliverables so
um you're putting a lot of time into
making sure that you have a quality
product that you have a quality that you
that you do quality work and you're very
up close and personal personable with
that but if you can detach from what
you're doing each day and and realize
you know on and some people are too
emotionally close to their product in
order to have a kind of bird's-eye view
of it um and that that goes like for
just when you're communicating with your
clients when you're trying to price your
services and when you're doing sales if
you can detach emotionally from that
product you are going to be a better
business person you can be a better you
know be more empathetic to your clients
when they don't understand what's going
on and it just makes you
more approachable if you can come at
this product as you know a little bit
less emotionally attached another reason
you want to detach from your products is
if you are you know building this
business out like if you if you do end
up doing freelance all the time
eventually you're going to want to be
able to bring more people on and be able
to you know sell sell more than just the
thing that you're selling and and the
way you do that is you know you have to
kind of let other developers other other
people kind of bring their craft in and
they're gonna do things different than
you but it's still it's still good so if
you can detach just from the product
itself a little bit and the other thing
is money so you need to understand money
before you jump into freelance and I
will say there's three stages of
freelance and basically there's the
first stage where you're kind of
learning freelance and learning how to
work with clients learning how to get a
deliverable produced that is a quality
product and you're basically kind of
like feeling it out I would say that
this stage is best done when when you
are still have a 9 to 5 salary and not
not the way that Steven and I did it
we did a lot of learning that first year
just trying to figure out what even like
how to go back and forth with clients or
you know how many rounds of what what
with a design you have to kind of do
like revisions and that kind of thing so
we were just learning way too much
without being paid full time and then
there's the second stage of freelance
where you are confident in the
deliverable that you've produced you've
worked with clients you can actually
lead them through a project and you are
filling up your time you are booking
basically based on your
you're selling your services based on
the time that you it takes you to
produce or the deliverables that are
produced with it and then after that the
third stage of freelance is you're no
longer selling your services based on
the time and deliverables but the actual
value that the clients are getting out
of your services and that's when you are
able to start leveraging your time where
you actually start to start making more
money than the time that you are putting
in so that's kind of the third stage and
I'll say time versus leverage so there's
also two ways of doing freelance where
you are you're actually you have the
time that you put in is okay you can
sell your services to a lot of clients
and if you're just trying to make up the
salary that you had given up then you
basically are going from one boss who
gives you a salary to a lot of busses
that give you a salary those clients
like the the level of expertise that you
have if you aren't leading them
throughout the whole process through the
sales and through everything else and
the clients actually become your boss
and you aren't your own boss as even
though that it's flexible like you have
the flexibility you have um you know you
can set your own prices it's still
there's this point where you know you go
from having many bosses to being your
own boss and actually leading the
clients and you know showing them what
the value is of your services and that's
where you you start to sell not just the
time and deliverables but the actual
value and so and so then you can start
being your expert being a consultant to
your clients and I'll also say pricing
like everyone gets very nervous about
when they go to price their services but
pricing is it's kind of it doesn't mean
anything
the actual price tag doesn't ever mean
anything the same service that you're
selling for five hundred dollars someone
else is selling for ten thousand some
the websites that we were building for
five thousand when you learned some
people are selling for thirty thousand
like there's no the actual price tag
does not matter now you can't like you
can't just like kind of say I'm a
freelancer I'm going to go sell my stuff
for this much money like there is value
that you have to put into the product
that is not based on deliverables or
based on the UM the time that you put in
the actual value that you're able to add
is is a little bit more if you can make
that results based and actually will
just move on to number three number
three if you can understand value of
your services and the value it comes
when you have a let's say you have a
client and you can see like where
they're at where they're struggling and
hit on those pain points like okay you
obviously need the exact thing that I am
doing here and then talk to them about
like what what is their benefit what um
what is where does this service get them
like what are their goals what are the
emotions tied to you know being a little
bit more free like having a lot more
flexibility with our website or being
able to bring in more leads through
their website or if you're doing apps
like what what money would they be able
to bring in with those apps or what
convenience is there if you can point
out like they're struggling now they
have a vision and they have a gap like
so that's where your services go
um and it's not necessarily about the
time that you put in or the deliverable
it's about you solving their problem and
if you are the one to solve their
problem then then they're going to give
you the money and if they believe that
you are the only one who can solve their
problem because you fully understand it
and they will because you fully
understand what their pain points are
then they're more likely to give you
what you asked for so the price becomes
and basically what you feel is worth the
value to them it's not about the
emotional benefits to value there are a
lot of different pains that people have
like if you're working with business
owners then a lot of their their pain is
like they can't they have a bottleneck
they can't continue to sell more or they
have to you know their their stress
their overstressed they they don't have
the systems in place that they need and
they don't have the revenue in place
like there's a lot of pain there and
it's not just business related all the
time sometimes it's you know their their
stress they're overworked they their
employees don't respect them or you know
there's all kinds of things that you can
find out that is a problem and then they
they are usually they are easy and they
have the pain and they're also making
mistakes and you can tell them like what
mistakes they are making you might lead
them to through that conversation and
ask them what mistakes they are making
or or where they want to be instead of
just putting up their defenses but and
then lead them to their vision and their
vision is used
something that brings the money
something that lessens their stress and
so it's that if you can anchor your
price to their emotions and the value to
what they need instead of what you are
needing and the money that you need to
bring in you're going to kind of it
makes them think that you are here for
them and it makes the project about
their needs and not about you
so even it's like count it's counter
intuitive to make it all about them but
that's really all that they care about
and it also establishes trust in you
they don't think that you're trying
you're just out there to get their money
they don't think that you're you know
they don't think that you need them as
much you know that you don't need the
sale and that creates establishes a lot
of trust and money follows trust so um
if you can get your clients to trust you
and a lot of that is you know having
good work and having good clients in the
past but then if you can establish trust
upfront with clients um that that like
leads them to want to give you more
money in the same is also true if you
are doing freelance for a company a
larger company except for their pain
points are going to be different so if
you're kind of filling doing coding for
agency or something like that then it's
more about you know like they are
needing someone who's dependable they're
needing someone who can get the job done
on their timeline you know they just
need to know that you are going to be
present that you're going to get the job
done and that you know their their
problem is more about impressing their
boss than it is about fulfilling the
clients need although some of that is
there too and so you just like kind of
if you can instead of selling
your perspective if you can find out
what their true needs are and a lot of
that is just asking them questions that
matter and you know don't be afraid to
ask the questions that you need to know
in order to price your services and the
number four thing that kind of reaches
across all of is confidence and if you
have confidence in the service that
you're providing if you can lead your
client through through the whole process
with confidence that you're going to get
the job done so what we found is a lot
of times when when you would go and go
into a first meeting where we're meeting
and talking about and you know what what
we're going to do for someone before we
ever get the job is that the client
themselves are not confident like they
don't know that we can get the job done
and people projects feelings on people
onto other people so they're then
feeling not confident would show up and
then we would start to feel less
confident about what we were offering
and it was kind of like this spiral
downwards where like by the end they're
just like well I'm not sure if the seed
is the right people for the job because
they don't know if they're the right
people for the job but we found when we
show up with confidence that that
projects back to them and when we say
like yes
you obviously have a need here and it's
our services that are going to help you
get the results that you want
and when we showed up with that
confidence then they just like it's kind
of a peaceful feeling that they get that
they're like yes this is who we need and
then we could quote them the price that
we want and like it it doesn't matter
the actual price is anchored to the
results
anchor2 our confidence
and we could tell them you know whatever
price it is and they would say okay how
can I make this work instead of like no
that's too much so um if you have I will
say like as you're starting out if you
can find confidence in one area of what
you're doing like say you're good at a
certain type of product if you can kind
of carry that and push your confidence
to other places you know find your
confidence in one area and then use it
you know with your clients you can find
your confidence here and then work -
yeah just there's there's wait if you
have the confidence in one place and you
can likely have find it in another place
and you just have to find it and use it
and I think when when you're starting
out when you're still in that first
phase of freelance where you're learning
your product in learning how to work
with clients you can you can tell them
like hey this is something you know you
can work work out with them what price
that needs to be I guess and if you're
if you're getting that project done like
you can use that project to fuel your
confidence for the next next project so
it doesn't really matter like what those
first few projects look like as long as
you're kind of like making sure that
your goal is confidence in the product
that you sell that's that's kind of like
our four things and I'll open it up to
questions so if you if you have any
questions about any specific things in
freelance I'm happy to answer
good
he's asking with contracts if we have
any specific payment schedules or
anything that we've learned about
contracts so um with contracts and I
will say like there's there's two parts
of contracts there is the statement of
work and that which is we basically turn
the proposal into the statement of work
and then there's a Terms of Service and
the terms of service is something that
we we went to a lawyer for but there are
Terms of Service online in artists ours
is probably very specific to design in
front-end web development and but that
statement of work outlines kind of the
scope of the project
and outlines the payment schedule and
really it just kind of depends on what
you want to get paid but I would say get
paid as much as you can up front we we
started out doing 5050 and in clients
were always pretty happy with that now
we try to do 100% upfront but we'll work
with people if they need to schedule out
their payments in it we kind of let them
bring it up we don't so if it's right
now our our package price is fifty five
hundred it's like an eight week program
where we do consulting for e-commerce
companies and we we say hey it's fifty
five hundred and they say hmm do you can
I schedule that out and they say yes
what are you thinking and then they'll
say okay can I split it into two
payments and then yeah yeah that works
or sometimes the last four three
payments like yeah that works we don't
like for them like we're not a bank so
we don't want to be scheduling out
payment plans for people they could go
to the bank they can put it on a credit
card and get payment plans that way and
but as far as as far as money goes like
you
cash flow is extremely important for
freelancers and if you are putting a lot
of work into a project where you get
paid upfront and then paid at the end
that cash flow like will dip each month
and be irregular so if you can't collect
all the money that you need then and
it's just a very unsure way of doing
business I guess we we don't do as many
contracts anymore
well we don't do as many statement of
works oh I will say um there is this
there's a contract on line so one thing
that we stopped doing is we've stopped
listening the deliverables in our
contracts because we are results focused
and we always we've always said that we
price on value which is not true
we've always pretty much just price on
what we need to make and when we started
pricing on the value and like the
results that people get then we were
also when we when we were doing that and
then still listing the deliverables in
the contract then people it still looks
like you're pricing based on the
deliverables they get which doesn't
always make sense because you know we
don't I mean until like that first few
meetings we don't even know like exactly
what the client needs I think that's
very true for scoping on code as well
like you get into a project and realize
like oh crap this looked really simple
but it's not like that's going to take a
few more weeks and so if you are listing
out the deliverables and not basing your
price on results then for one
you were probably undercutting yourself
up front and not not leaving room for
there to be the extra time or you know
you just
yeahit's you're not in your head are you
agree
yes
right and that's he was saying yeah you
kind of build yourself into a corner and
don't allow yourself to pivot and that's
very true that's what we were finding in
our class in our contracts is we would
say oh we can do this and this and this
for you and then when this and this
wasn't we would we would do those things
and then it wouldn't provide the results
and they were and then we would come
back to the client and say actually um
you don't you don't need this it turns
out you need this and we've already lost
that trust that needed to be there
upfront and so you actually build a lot
of front of trust up front if you can
say we don't know what you need we need
to do we need to like dive into your
business and and learn what you need and
then we can build out and some people
also do like a discovery package
discovery is kind of a buzz buzz word
but where you know you take two weeks
and really dive in to what they what
they're doing they are paying for that
and they can take your kind of
prescription and go you know take it to
someone else or they can stay on and
take and you know have you do the work
but and those two weeks are well it's a
lot of research on your on your part and
it also kind of sets up your project for
success so you're not like prescribing
anything before you actually know about
their business so having the discovery
up front and then doing all that stuff
in the background but is that mm-hmm
any other questions
mm-hmm um the question was how do I or
what is my advice for someone who is
working on Fiverr or some of the gate
development sites and moving to doing
their own work I guess building their
own business is that kind of what yeah
I'd say for one you you aren't
completely like you are learning how to
do this if you are learning how to work
with clients and that's not a bad way to
start because that does give you leads
to begin with but to make the jump I
think you still have to understand like
one detach from that's going to be
really hard to detach from if you're
selling your services for so much little
amounts of money and building those
larger company businesses selling your
own services you have to realize that
you know someone is charging fifty
dollars for whatever that someone else
is charging five thousand for that same
work like if you can realize like you
can get that larger amount of money and
realize that like that's not the fiber
does not define your business that
there's a lot more potential just like
making the being able to jump is kind of
like you do have that capability to jump
and so you should take it I guess
don't let like that mindset hold you
back and I say you still have the work
you still have the confidence that you
built from that and you can use that to
put towards your future clients and
there is you also have to learn how to
get those clients and a lot of that is
you know talking confidently about their
needs and talking confidently about like
what they're struggling with and then
you know making it
like you're the one service that you
like the service that you provide is the
answer to their problems so kind of
learning how to get clients and through
the way that you talk about your
services they don't just show up at your
door so does that answer
yeah um so referral is a good way to go
especially if you have a history of
clients that love you that's a great way
to stay afloat and you want that so that
you want kind of that base if you don't
have clients that have trusted you in
the past then it's hard to get future
clients to trust you um but see you
tonight right now are using Facebook to
get clients and that is kind of a a very
new thing like that's it this year thing
since we've hired this consultant and it
works but basically with any social
media um any profile like if you are
talking about your service your
expertise and kind of the paint that
like the mistakes that people are making
that gets people curious and it gets it
gets them kind of interested in what
you're saying and then you need a way to
get people to see that and what we do is
we go into Facebook groups and you know
post there and we're gonna be using
Facebook Ads we haven't gotten there yet
we're getting a lot of great feedback
without doing ads right now um and so if
you can same with LinkedIn if you can
you know prime your profile like like
this is what I do this is my expertise
and then go find people that are your
ideal customer and then they see like if
the you one of the things that you do
have to do is like if you can pinpoint
exactly what their needs are and
pinpoint who your customer is like just
the the way you can talk to them like
they automatic an automatically say like
oh this is exactly what I need then
you're halfway there
any other questions
you're not might just gonna add that
when we first got started like you might
not have that knowledge base to
communicate with people a lot like I
literally we printed off business cards
and I was walking around to small
businesses saying hey I make websites
here's you know so you got to do what
you got to do at the beginning to kind
of build up your experience if you don't
have any clients work at all you could
start off like talk to some small
nonprofits or something and just
volunteer to help them out like hey I'll
build you a website for free and then
you'll always have that work to refer
back to you
I just was making sure like there's kind
of an intermediate step there where you
kind of scramble around and learn what
you're doing while you're trying to talk
to people basically if people know they
have a problem and they know that you
solve it then the more people you meet
that have a problem the more you're
gonna find that want you to solve their
problem so it is kind of a numbers game
where if you can just meet more people
who have problems and make it make them
realize like you can help them and not
it doesn't have to be like a slimy sales
Scelzi thing yeah go ahead
yeah and your question was if I can sum
them up for the camera if yeah if we can
it's hard to find a Nisha up front until
we've done the work to decide yeah
we did not know our nisha up front we
actually we worked with a score mentor
about a year and a half ago and she
advised us to niche down and so that's
when we started realizing okay well this
is the work we enjoy doing let's let's
continue to narrow it down and we spent
like a year like actually narrowing down
on to e-commerce we had just decided
like consumer products or and that kind
of thing and a lot of that was like our
own expertise that kind of developed in
and what we liked to do that helped us
narrow down but I will say like if you
are able to narrow down your target your
ideal customer for one like that makes
it easier for them to realize that you
are the one person that can help them
and it also makes your work easier
like if you're able to systemize the
stuff that you do that means that you're
able to leverage your time and charge
more based on their results so you're
not charging based on your deliverables
and the time that you put in and then
then you like just having being able to
repeat the work that you're doing and
sell it again and again if there's any
part of your process that you can do
that for then
you're not starting over from scratch
for each client it doesn't take like 16
weeks to get it done it's it's something
that you can make money and sell so
niching down is actually a really it
makes it fun to be honest i mean it was
fun to kind of explore our talents at
first whenever we were learning like
what we can do and but now I I get I
just enjoy being able to help more
people and I can help more people if if
I can sell them the same thing over and
over again so
no any other questions if how far have
you guys gotten with your coding like
and only a few people have started
freelance how many people are like doing
this for full-time like coding for a
full-time job okay yeah so freelance is
probably a little ways out there I will
say that if you are able to freelance
for people and start selling your
services that's a really fast way to
learn because you have it like an actual
real life problem in front of you and if
you can just you know tell your client
like hey this is a learning process
every every project is different so of
course I'm going to be taking time to
make sure that you get your results
that's a really great way to get started
in freelance without feeling guilty or
without feeling like you're doing this
client a disservice if you can just be
honest that front like hey every project
is different for me I want to take a lot
of time make sure that you get the
results that you want and you know maybe
you give them a price that you feel is
fair but if you can just get going on
that
like that's how you're going to learn
the quickest and there's um this is a
really great community like I'm sure
Kimberly and a lot of other people here
even in this room would be here to help
you you know if you were to hit a
standstill
I think tech Lahoma slack is also a good
place to go for answers but like just
this real-world experience of freelance
is going to push you a lot farther than
you know a nine-to-five job where you're
doing the same thing every day having
those different projects up front
like learning what Nietzsche like that's
going to that's a really good first step
in you know like Steven was saying all
it all it takes is like you know passing
out a business car it doesn't have to be
fancy business card just meeting some
people who might need some help so yeah
any other questions before I huh
okay yep well thank you for having me um
it's good to talk to you guys
Thanks
[Applause]